nouveau produit qui vient d'arriver chez
samsung vous ne voyez donc titre si vous
cliquez ci vous le voyez samsung galaxy
à 52 s on avait lieu à 52 on connaissait
la gamme à ocoee d'ailleurs toujours là
gamin avec plein de produits super
intéressant et le à 50 e à saint quentin
maintenant le à 50 2 qui est sorti je
vous êtes déjà présenté d'ailleurs si
vous le connaissez pas la vidéo est
quelque part par là où par là et puis là
il vient de sortir une déclinaison en
baisse alors je vous emmène chez samsung
avait une présentation aujourd'hui je
vous emmène découvrir ce nouveau
smartphone qu'est ce qu'ils proposent de
mu est ce qu'il est intéressant à quel
prix tout ça quoi comment vous allez
voir on en parle c'est super intéressant
en plus il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'actu de samsø vous verrez
beaucoup de titres avec samsung samsung
galaxy z flip 3 est folle de trois il ya
la watch quatre classiques dont je vous
parlais ces quelques jours et à les bugs
de enfin bref il ya beaucoup d'actualité
chez samsung ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
de lancements mais c'est intéressant et
l'ajustement par tout de suite du
samsung galaxy à 52 s
[Musique]
je peux t'appeler mathilde du coup
aux jambes est il
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien
quand un des nouveaux venus chez samsung
tu t'occupes de la gamme a exactement
gamme à ses smartphones bref revenons
bon alors nous on parle de gamins on
parle de fog récemment par un peu plus
tard alors aujourd'hui des nouveaux
modèles et vous marie surpris ce matin
je suis arrivé je me suis dit tiens
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui chez
samsung et joua vous avez un nouveau
modèle dans la gamme assez le à 52 s
d'actes mans c'est quoi ce bazar c'est
le magnifique à 52 s magnifique parce
qu'il a une toute nouvelle finition
on peut voir ici il y en a aussi en
lavande face à la la land en noir et or
je trouve ça c'est de l'or en blond bas
les magnifiques ok ça marche alors
pourquoi venir faire un modèle s sur la
gamme à 52 fais ce que tu as une réponse
à ça et ben oui tout simplement parce
qu'on voulait venir apporter du coup une
performance supplémentaire à cette gamme
voile et le but du coût de ce modèle à
52 s c'est simplement d'apporter du coup
un smartphone beaucoup plus puissant
ouais à ce niveau diana ok qu'est ce
qu'on avait avant sur l'a52 rappelle moi
au terme de blue cross intérieur on
avait un processeur snapdragon
750 g ouais et là on vient apporter du
snapdragon
778 sujet d'accord ok qui sait la caméra
sera coupée cherchait donc elle tombe
pas tout va bien ok 778 jay exactement
hockey 40% plus puissant que le 750
hockey et qu'il ya une partie graphique
optimisée à 80 % de plus donc amène là
un bon buzz de performance sur cette
gamme art et ensuite on conserve ce qui
se faisait de bien du coup sûr leur
cinquante d'eux avec une caméra en
quadruple capteur 14 principales de 64
mégapixels donc ultra détaillés avec
stabilisation type web qui permet
d'avoir les gammes des photos et des
vidéos qui sont toujours ultra net ça
marche et ensuite on a toujours la
certification ip67 donc qui permet
d'immerger le téléphone pendant 30
minutes un mètre de profondeur le fait
par ne le fait pas si jamais le club
mais c'est si jamais il pleut alors si
jamais un de vos amis vous pousse dans
une piscine par exemple vous allez trop
loin smartphones qui résiste aux quais
canon ça marche donc ça c'est cool ok
donc on est toujours dans l'air dans un
smartphone je dirais c'est le plus haut
de gamme du milieu de gamme chez vous
c'est la gamme à l'exacte bruxelles dit
des bêtises donc smartphones qui va
effectivement pour me refaire du gaming
pour venir s'amuser pour venir faire des
photos pour visionner des films et des
séries sur un grand écran rappelle moi
on est sur du 6 5 pouces voit ses
mandats un écran qui est grand et
surtout sur l'écran si je peux préciser
une petite chose non
je résiste part ça il
précisé on est sur dix super amoled à
dubaï ok là on met on l'a vu déjà sur
l'a52 le sambrien on l'avait déjà sur la
route et en deux mais dupont le conserve
un recours ça malgré le l'excédent de
puissance du coup pour ajoutant qu est
sûre donc ça veut dire que tu vas
vraiment l'axé gaming en disant vous
aurez ce qui est de mieux en terme de
fluidité pour venir jouer sans aucun
problème exactement ok trop cool ce
smartphone il est dispo quand il est
dispo dès le 1er septembre ok donc très
mal en point comme samsung com et dans
tous les distributeurs gouaille
habituelle hockey chez tous les
distributeurs habituels c'est ça et pour
l'accompagner on a une superbe de
lancement des bois qui court jusqu'au 15
octobre du 1er septembre au 15 octobre
le prix du smartphone est de 459 euros
contre combien pour le à 52
il était à 459 également d'accord il
baisse a eu lieu à 52 ou pas du coup le
à 52 et remplacé du coup donc le à 52 et
disparaît du catalogue chez vous
exactement sur la 105 g sur la version 5
g et sur la version une version 4g aussi
sur la version 4g convient de continuer
d'accord et et d'opter donc ok j'ai
compris le à 52 vous vous l'aurez plus
au catalogue mais pour autant on peut
retrouver chez elle 5 j'ai alors appelé
en catalan à 52,5 des excuses moi vous
l'avez plus au catalogue mais pour
autant si je vais chez darty boulanger
et consorts et peut-être qui va on va le
retrouver encore un petit peu le temps
que les stocks soient épuré à ce moment
là parce qu'il sera un peu moins cher
après chaque distributeur et vivre de
façon à petit sa politique tarifaire
d'accord mais vous il ya plus de tarifs
conseillés sur le à 50 de vue pour vous
il est plus référencé ans et plus une
référence on le remplace du coup par le
nouveau ok c'est super trop cool il ya
d'autres produits qui vont avoir cette
dénomination est ce dans la gamme alors
on en a déjà en fait ouais on a déjà un
an 0,2 s oui l'entrée de gamme c'est
vraiment dans l'entrée de gamme mais je
pense que je sois sûr du c'ur du à 40,2
sur des choses comme ça 72 ils coûtent
jusqu'à présent c'est une première du
coup sûr ce type de smartphone à ce
niveau de gamme ok aujourd'hui notre
volonté c'est vraiment pour le à 52
d'offrir à quelque chose de plus
performant et plus généreux en termes de
français écoutent très cool donc un
produit qui sera disponible début
septembre le lien dans la description
quand il sera disponible pour l'instant
je pense que l'on aura pas mais dès que
ce sera possible je mets le lien de la
description qui testera parce que c'est
un produit qui est intéressant à voir ce
que cet excédent de performance nous
nous apporte on connaissait déjà la 52e
donc je pense pas que ça va bien
complètement révolutionné l'histoire
mais on va gagner quelques petits pas en
termes de benchmark là dessus donc et
merci beaucoup bastia avec plaisir je
parlais juste
ceux du coup par l'offre de lancement
parce que moi a commencé sur le timing
on l'a pris les idées moi surtout
l'offre de lancement c'est qu'on offre
google l'est audio avec ok tout achat ou
durée 52s cinq gîtes rôle donc c'est
vraiment super parce que google et
youtube à sept remplaçants du globe et
du tout ça permet d'avoir une bonne
enceinte connectique vous offrez leur un
match très très bien ok général pour
beuvry bonne entame de coupe
voilà vous savez tout sur ce nouveau
produit samsung galaxy à 52 s à vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire ce que c'est un produit qui
pourrait vous tenter d'ailleurs si vous
avez lu à 52 ou lui à 51 ne changeait
pas il reste très actuelle même si le à
52 s est plus puissant plus musclée et
plus performant on aura très bientôt
beaucoup de samsung et de plein d'autres
choses donc ça c'est cool des bisous
pour les soins de beaucoup d'amour et
benneteau